hello everyone welcome to a very nice
game from the Croatian chesley it was
played this Sunday my opponent is a
Croatian candidate master
Mariano kasha and I I prepared for a
different opponent but he didn't show up
so I plating is this gentleman instead
and as I was expecting
efore my preparation didn't really make
all that much of a difference as Mari
and here played d4 on the first move but
ok I didn't prepare all that much maybe
an hour but you know that that tends to
happen so without further ado let's
check out the game my opponent opened
the width D for a like I said sorry
about that with d5 by me so just going
for the Queens gambit declined as you as
you might expect with each six nights
the c3 and now Knight to f6 the Queens
gambit the client is on the board he
went for Bishop to g5 Bishop to e7 and
now and early trade in the center C
captures he captures and III oh ok this
is all standard stuff I castled here he
developed the Bishop Bishop to d3 and to
avoid any any future targets
I immediately played h6 so he retreated
Bishop to h4 and now the the most
popular moves well in 2009 in 2019 at
least our b6 and c6 here but I played c5
I of course thought about playing c6 I
thought the ayats are very very nice
safe move you know guarding the d5 pawn
but I thought okay if it's if if I can
play c5 I would much rather play c5 and
I want to develop my knight over to c6
and okay he played the D characters on
c5 and I'm not going to recapture right
away I can always do that later and now
nice to see six this was my idea now
also not allowing any b4 ideas but I was
really worried about him protecting this
point I can always for example undermine
with a5 but okay he continued
development with Knight - g - e - and
now their their disposition has been
reached before but bishop characters on
c5 was always played here I play Bishop
to g4 here and already as of move 10 we
have a completely new game so here my
idea is okay I'm painting the Knight and
I would like him to create some
weaknesses in the position either by
playing f3 after which
I can move the bushel but then after I
recapture on c5 I will have this very
nice diagonal or maybe just a ch3 and
then well I just wanted to create some
weaknesses but instead he and pinned he
played Queen to d2 and Queen to d2 gave
me some ideas that well the Queen is on
a very odd square especially in the
Queens gambit declined very rarely will
you see well at least I rarely see a
queen on d2 so here instead of just
continuing development you know maybe
maybe recapturing and c5 maybe going to
rook c8 or something like that
I played Knights to e5 which is a bit of
an unprincipled move as I already
developed that piece of course but I did
it because it just seemed logical I'm
attacking his light square bishop here I
don't expect him to move the bishop here
one reason being that he didn't develop
his rook on a1 and if he goes to b1 well
then his rook is just stuck on a one he
will have to again waste a temple moving
the bishop to get the rock into the game
so I didn't really feel like he would do
that and I can always just capture it
it's a very strong piece on the other
hand if Bishop goes to sea to always
have Knight to c4 as an option sometimes
maybe then I will have a force his Queen
to go to c1 as the Queen will have to
guard the b2 pawn and then the rook will
again be stuck on the a1 square so I
just thought it was a it was a nice idea
here he decided to ignore this move by
the night and he casts out here which is
which is a great move and I decided well
I took some time here and I thought
about maybe just you know gobbling and
gobble up that [ __ ] right away I
thought maybe just continued development
but I decided to sacrifice a pawn here I
wasn't sure if he was gonna take the
pawn but I thought it was it was a good
idea as I would I would get to keep my
bishop pair for a pawn and I would get
some nice initiative
so I played Bishop captures on c5 now
and now I'm offering him if he wants to
give up his Bishop I'll recapture and
then he can grab the d5 pawn the other
way around doesn't work because because
of my knight on e5 if he goes the knight
captures here Queen captures and Bishop
captures on f6 there won't be any checks
here but with picking up the Queen
because the bishop is attacked twice now
I can just capture it and there are no
tricks here because his Queen on d2 is
under attack again all of this
is well possible for me because the
queen is on such an odd square but he
did go he did grab the pond which is
which is the engine enjoys this move he
played Bishop captures on f6 I played
Queen captures on f6 and the Knight
captures on d5 and okay I'm down upon
but I have a better pair my night is
very nicely placed on e5 and the queen
is on f6 so basically I just have to get
my ropes into the game but I have a very
active game and here I thought for some
maybe 10 minutes I thought about if
Knight to f3 works the problem is it
doesn't and I'm very glad I found it
that it doesn't because it would be it
would be pretty bad if I if I didn't
find it because if you go neither three
right away with check G captors and
Queen captures on f3 of retinic this
idea then Knight the g3 saves the day
for white because yes but h3 now
threatens mate and also you're
threatening to pick up the rook on f1
problem is the knight and g3 now guards
d4 square and you have Bishop to b4 you
the Queen now have to move you guard the
g2 squared there is no mate and after
the Queen moves you're just gonna get to
the rook to safety with tempo and white
is perfectly fine there is no
compensation here for my sacrificed
piece so instead I just moved the Queen
a closer to the White King I played
Queen to h4 and here there are there are
a lot of options here but it's not easy
to make a move for white for example the
Queen is still on a very odd square on
d2 as the King is now on g1 so for
example if you try to kick away some
attackers I can always just capture that
you can never recapture because Knight
f3 check picks up the Queen again we we
have this theme of the Queen on a very
very weird square so other moves are
also not not that great for example f3
is a very complicated move
if f3 attacking the bishop we have this
line of rook a to d8
going after the night here now F captors
and g4 rook captures on d5 now you can
pick up the loop with Bishop to h7 check
King captures and now Queen captures on
d5 but now as the F pawn is no longer
guarding d3 Khan you can play Bishop
captures on e3 trick King to h1 and now
we get this position after Knight
captures on g4 that's just completely
crazy
there's no immediate way for black to
take advantage of this for example if h3
I can go for this perpetual check night
checks King goes back to h2 and now I
can either go in I do four check night
after jugnu g4 check to have a perpetual
or I can continue for example attacking
with at five but it's a real really a to
crazy position but I don't know i when i
played this Queen to h4 move I thought
h3 and f3 are just two weakening moves
for white that white shouldn't weaken
his position like this on the other hand
there is a there is an idea that is best
for white and that's just the continued
development for example look 8 2 c1
it comes with an attack on the bishop so
it makes a very very much sense and
after I defend it now you go night eat
f4 and this night here is just a
beautiful piece now for white
it really just defends everything there
are no I mean the game the game
basically continues white is better
white is up upon but I I was I was happy
playing a position down upon which the
bishop pair for example if I go g5 to
take away my knight take away his Knight
it doesn't really work because of a
knight f6 check King g7 and he can bring
just the other night here over to d5 and
again there are no tricks here because
any Knight of 3 action white can just
capture and his knight from F 6 guards
the G 4 square so the Queen would not
have any attacking chances here it would
be it would be a very nice idea so after
Queen to h4 rook 8 2 c1 definitely the
way to go but my opponent played Knight
eat the c3 and as soon as he played this
I thought ok now he just removed one of
the defenders remove one of the
defenders away from the Queen side it's
it's very suspicious this this Knight
eat the c3 move and here I give the
position some thought and I found a very
nice idea so you can pause the video
here and try to find this move that I
played it's not a difficult one but you
know take a few seconds if you if you
need so for those of you who were able
to find it congratulations you are an
excellent
creator of of nice chances and for those
of you who just want to enjoy it so it
is Knight to f3 now because now there is
no nice to return at the g3 as in the
line that we've already shown so he has
to capture the night if he doesn't he
just loses the Queen on D - will G
captures now I played Bishop captures
and now my threat is the simple Queen G
for mate so how do you prevent this it's
it's not easy to prevent it you have to
play you have to move the rook rook C
want to make some room for the King and
then the game continues rook a to d8 I
just create some threats along the
defiled his Queen still occupies the D
file and after the Queen moves now I go
Queen g4 check into f1 finish three
check King II one and now I capture
Bishop captures on d5 Knight captures
and rook captures and we get this
position where the material on the board
is now equal and well his position is is
just worse as he does have a king here I
can start picking up the H point I can
bring the other look into the game and
it just would be a better position for
black if not outright winning but you
know it would still require precise play
and well that's that's always easier
said than done but he played Knight to
e4 instead his idea is that it's similar
when tonight was on e - and the knight
can now retreat the g3 from efore and
the defend from any threats but it
doesn't work here here I actually have a
force the winning sequence so once again
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this winning sequence well I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
threatener of mates on h2 and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
the move is actually Bishop to d6 this
is the quickest way to win if you found
rook e8 to DA - that also works black
would have a winning position after
rocket 88 for example but if you found
something like
quinta h3 or for example Queens the g4
check that doesn't work for example
Queens you for check Knight G 3 blocks
Queen h3 threatens mate and now Knight
f4 defense mate and attacks the Queen
you would now have to retreat with the
Queen and now white just continues
playing you're being up material for
example rook fc-1 and white white is
just in a winning position here there is
no tricks here you can't start pushing
the H pawn as the Knights really nicely
covered EDH v square white is just
here on the other hand you don't really
have the option of going Queen to h3
right away to threaten mate it's the
same night if four attacks the queen
guards the G to square you move the
Queen with check the other night blocks
and we have the exact same position so
the only move that really forces
resignation basically is Bishop to d6
and this is what I played and I was very
happy that I found it and that such an
opportunity presented itself especially
especially against a strong player and
in such a short game 17 moves this is
very very nice with the black pieces so
of course I was very happy I was very
happy that my intuition was correct that
it was okay to give up the pawn for for
the bishop pair for some nice initiative
on the Kings side and he didn't he
didn't feel threatened enough this night
the night eat the sea to remove was just
allowing this to happen it was it was a
it was a you know bad luck for him but
it's not it's not much but I'm very
happy that I took the opportunity that
that was presented to me so here there
is nothing to do the threat is just
Queen to h2 mate and if you don't do
something for example if you capture it
now in g4 is just mate in one as you
don't have a knight to retreat the g3
with and if you don't do it if you go to
g3 which is kind of the point of Bishop
to d6 if you go to g3 now I go Queen h3
and now you cannot defend mate now
Knight to f4 yes it does guard and the
tax but my bishop is ready just captures
and there is no move for white
characters and the Queen to g2 will be
made
so after this Bishop to d6 move he
resigned the game and well I was I was
very happy that I was able to create
this small miniature the soul say but
yeah I want a very nice game we as we as
a team lost so that's that's unfortunate
but you can't always always win
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it a lot we are always asking
for more of my game so I thought this
one was well interesting because of the
the worth positioning of of White Queen
on d2 so III do hope you enjoyed it and
all the opportunities that present
themselves because of this
we're positioning of the Queen on d2 but
yeah I once again I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to think I'm you're
talking Steven Anderson and Stanley
Mandel for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video Sarah thank all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the video World Cup checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
continuing with the conclusion of the
capablanca saga and yes we will have a
new vote on what the next big series
will be so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day